(modern music)
- [Peter] The frame shop here
at the Museum of Modern
Art is actually unique.
We do most of the framing
for the collection,
for exhibitions and traveling exhibitions.
Anything that is wood is made inside.
We have a small woodworking shop.
We have seven people
working at the department
but we produce a
tremendous amount of work.
In the case of Cristina's World,
it can't be too modern.
It has to fit with a certain context.
Ultimately the best frame is the one
that doesn't call attention to itself.
The frame has a way of
pushing and pulling.
Normally if you had a landscape,
it would be what is called a cove,
a frame that comes out and
creates a window into the work.
This works in reverse.
This one the painting come forward
and the frame goes back.
The first thing I wanted
to do was to understand
why the frame was not working.
What is it about the frame
that could be improved upon?
It was not original to the work.
Framers talk about frames
in terms of weight,
not necessarily in terms of look.
The frame could be too
light, it could be too heavy.
The frame that it had
was a little bit light.
A little (mumbles) even though it
had a gold band on the inside.
The gilded liner of the
frame was actually touching
the chimneys of the house.
Wyeth spent a great
deal of time and effort
coming all the way too the edge.
So what's important that
we see the entire panel.
This painting actually is floating.
There are two frames in one here.
It's not damaging or causing any pressure.
Many of the frames that Wyeth selected
for his work were painted
and he always wanted to pick
a color from the painting
and use that color in the frame.
If the artist does it it's one thing,
but a framer should not be doing that.
I picked what I thought
would be a very natural wood
and basically set the
painting within the frame
as a beautiful little jewel.
The whole frames is made
from one single piece of wood
so that the grain just continues.
We knew from the beginning that we
were going to have a gold band.
I decided to put a cove on the inside
to separate the gilding.
The next step is to design the panel.
One element that would justify angling
the panel to the outside
is the roof of the house.
Then you have to decide how
that panel is going to end.
This is an abrupt stop.
It has another angle to the back.
The frame will appear
almost floating on the wall
because when you light it
it's going to cast a shadow behind it.
After you make the frame
then you start thinking
about the different stains.
Once you put a stain on the
panel you can't take it off
and that's where you come in.
We're making as many samples as possible
using the exact same piece of wood.
You can see the difference
if you put them next to it.
These are very very minor variations
that ultimately you
don't pay attention to,
but in terms of the framing
it's rather important
and it has a way of affecting
how we see a painting.
(modern music)